...
-Quand je suis seule
et que je peux rêver,
..je rêve que je suis
dans tes bras,
..je rêve que
je te fais tout bas...
Une déclaration...
Ma déclaration.
Quand je suis seule
et que je peux inventer,
..que tu es là
tout prêt de moi,
..je peux m'imaginer tout bas...
Une déclaration...
Ma déclaration.
Juste deux ou trois mots d'amour..
..pour te parler de nous.
Deux ou trois mots
de tous les jours,
..c'est tout.
Je ne pourrai jamais
te dire tout ça,
..je voudrais tant
mais je n'oserai pas.
J'aime mieux mettre
dans ma chanson...
Une déclaration...
Ma déclaration.
...
Juste deux ou trois mots d'amour..
..pour te parler de nous.
Deux ou trois mots
de tous les jours,
..c'est tout.
Quand je suis seule
et que je peux rêver,
..je rêve que
je suis dans tes bras,
..je rêve que je te fais tout bas...
Une déclaration...
Ma déclaration.
Je veux des souvenirs avec toi,
des voyages avec toi,
..des images avec toi.
Je me sens bien
quand tu es là.
-UNE DECLARATION.
MA DECLARATION.
-Je t'aime quand tu es triste,
que tu ne dis rien,
..je t'aime quand je te parle
et que tu ne m'écoutes pas.
Je me sens bien
quand tu es là.
Une déclaration.
Ma déclaration.